Hello everyone in this video I
am a two student did not manage you do well in
brother ji men
and generally I make me video and English but I have received so main
request from
student about making a video in hindi
date par de changer think I make  This
particular video in Hindi So, nothing is going on,
so if your Mains result is not good then you have
three options, the
first option is this, the first option is that
you can get admission in any institute on the basis of Mains only.  The
second option for taking admission is off
course. This is from the first option itself that
you should try for all the remaining exams. There are different state
level examinations, you should try for them
and on their basis,
take admission in any institute.  And you have the third option, the
third option is that you take the drop once,
so if you are
thinking of taking admission in any institute based on your JEE Mains result
or on the basis of whatever state level examination you have, then
I have told you one thing.  This is a request, this is a suggestion
and also a request that
please when you take admission, try
not to go to any random third air college,
now you will feel that all your friends are
going to some college, you will sit at home
or
think of something else.  So Bibi and left out,
this is wrong, you have to think, I think it would be
absolutely wrong because in the matter of your
career, only you are
responsible, not your friends, not
anyone else, so whatever is best for you, whatever is best for
you.  It is
also true that
if your situation is such that you have to
go to one college compulsorily,
I too had already
taken the drop last time and  If this is your last
opportunity, then this year is your last
opportunity, so you will have to go to some college,
even if it is a third air
college, so please,
my suggestion is that you
please do not take admission in such departments of mechanical and civil in such colleges.
I myself  I am a
professor of mechanical engineering in IT Kharakpur itself. I
am in the mechanical engineering
department. Despite that, I am saying
that you should not take admission in such third air colleges.
You will be very surprised to hear this in such type of department of mechanical and civil engineering department.
But the reason is simple, see, there is a
misconception among many students that since
all of them are in the ranks of mechanical and civil,
then their
syllabus and their education is
completely wrong, mechanical
engineering and civil engineering.  All these are quite a
lot and a lot of expertise is required to read them. The faculty
in such type of third grade college do not have this expertise. Did you know they are not properly qualified but this is
not the only qualification you have.  I have to
say this with great sadness but it is true that I have had the
opportunity of internet acting and
interviewing some of them, so there is
something lacking in them, they themselves do
not know many things, so
what will they teach you, so
what is this argument?  For all other departments,
I am suggesting you that if you have to
take admission in 38 colleges, then
you should take computer science and IT,
take information technology,
then does this argument not apply in that,
what if the faculty there suddenly
All of them are good only in those two departments, it
is not so, in such type of
colleges, the teachers in those departments are
also not good in Computer Science and IT,
but
these departments are such that their syllabus has
a lot of online materials ready available on it.
You will get all these in full mantra,
so if you take admission,
unfortunately you are studying from such a teacher,
then despite that you
can apply for your education yourself. Online Resources:
Professor of Mechanical Engineering,
Professor of Engineering, We are such people.  We have
also made some videos and have kept
a lot of videos in my channel. The
thing is that there are
such types of things in Mechanical Engineering and Civil Engineering
that thousands of people can get them online without you,
they are
not actually present in physical form or they are not understood.  If you can do
some coding from D Nature of D department then this type of education is not done in this way and
compare it, there are less online resources related to computer science, it is
okay, you search for it,
you will get as many resources as you can in computer
science variety.  You will
not get that much resources online. Yes, there are imple lecturers but they are not enough.
Okay, so keep this thing in
mind while going to third tier
college. Please
do not go to such department. If
you are talking about the
third option in Mechanical Civil.  If you want to take a drop,
I have already made a video
on this topic, so I will
quickly tell you the summary of it in this video.
Think for yourself, whatever be
your academic status, your
parents will not be able to say this.  Brothers and sisters,
no one will be able to speak and certainly those
from the coaching institute will not be able to
speak, even if they are able to speak, they will not speak because
see, they have a financial incentive,
if you try again then I will
also get coaching from them.  If they
take it, their business will increase, then you will definitely
say that
drop it again, drop it again,
then you yourself have to decide, even my speaking is
not going to do anything, you have to decide yourself
whether you should drop it or not.
Otherwise, you should think carefully, first of all,
think that if your G-Mains
result is so bad that you are
not getting any admission in any good college, then
how far can you go by dropping one year this time.
It is possible that you will find the flood, it is possible to move forward, but
your own discipline and
control over yourself, will you be able to fill this gap in this limited time or
not and if you are not able to, then what will you do
in engineering?  Should I go or not? It sounds
very bad,
but if you do it a little then it is true and you will have to
face it, there is no option for it,
so you think that maybe
your talent is in some other direction.
So, when you are young then why would you be
unnecessarily pursuing such engineering? If you
get a job then don't give too much importance to all these,
decide for yourself and if you are thinking of dropping it then you are thinking that
yes, I will fire you.  I will definitely find the next point,
so
please don't think that if I will
work very hard and I also
know how to work hard, I have the ability to do it,
despite that I am saying that if your
strategy is that yes, I
will work very hard.  And due to this, my result will be good
next time, so this is a bit of a fantasy
type thing, this is
not a plane, okay, so I am
clearly saying that there is no plane,
this is just a hope, I mean a fantasy
hope.  So it is not going to be less than this, what you have to do is that
you have to think very well and
with a cool mind that why
you have not passed this time, is
it because of your problem
solving ability?  There is something missing
or we can
solve the problem but it takes
too much time to do it.
You have to increase your speed. There may be a point
and there may also be a point like this, for
example maybe you are in time.  We also do these
which are somewhat straight
forward problems but which are a little
back-breaking type problems which are done by
combining different topics
from different chapters and if
you get a little stuck in these types of problems
then you
In the Very Fox Way, we identify
that this is my problem, so you can
reduce it like a spear on the problem,
you can put effort on it, it
is fine in the Fox Way, but if you
drop it before deciding, then it will give you  It is
very important to identify, okay so
this is my suggestion, these are my points
and before finally dropping, think once about
what is the condition of your family, maybe
you have a decent result in J-Mains
and you are studying in a
middle level institute.  If
you are able to go to a normal type of institute and get
a good job in computer science or IT, then
what is the harm in that? If the situation of your family
is such that you need a job as soon as possible,
then consider all this.  You have to do it yourself,
okay, I am saying again, go to some
coaching institute
[Music]
Aunty ji, Uncle ji, do
n't hit all these buttons, okay, decide for yourself
which one will be best for you, okay?
But what will be the most optimum decision and
accordingly you decide then my best
wishes are with all of you which is very
best, thank you.